make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with invincible yes
we are okay cool so here's the thing
right like if you guys remember the last
video that we did you ended up having
mark who basically brought his
stepbrother back home and i'll have the
playlist for invincible down in the
description
but uh but mark brought his stepbrother
back home right so basically the the son
of omniman
on a different planet right and and what
this does is it kind of picks up with
this idea of like mark's mom raising him
right now initially when mark brought
him back
it was really kind of a shock for mark's
mom right just because of the fact that
one
like everything had seemingly happened
so fast and she never really had a
chance to cope
we talked about that in the last video
that was the biggest issue that mark's
mom had
is i guess she coped but her method of
coping was alcohol right she just kind
of delved into alcoholism now that's one
of the things that i loved about
invincible for us as regular people we
all have our own coping mechanisms right
some of us work out some of us make
comic book youtube videos others end up
kind of jumping into
less productive things and alcohol is a
very
easy thing to fall into the trap of
alcoholism is all too easy right i've
got
members of my family who have fallen
prey to that because it's very easy to
kind of numb the pain right to just sort
of succumb
to that drunken stupor and then you just
don't feel anything but you don't feel
any real sadness you don't really feel
any real remorse you just kind of
don't really feel a whole lot and the
result is that it makes the pain go away
and that really i think is a testament
more to what deborah was going through
than anything
else because seemingly her entire world
came crashing down
like that right in the blink of an eye
your husband turns out to be a villain
from a different planet who
openly admitted he never really cared
about you at all right your son is this
walking talking reminder of the man that
you that you loved you know that you
essentially lost right i mean that
that's that's kind of the crazy thing
and so for
mark's mom having a little kid to take
care of here
is a great thing for her because it kind
of gives her a chance to sort of start
fresh right to kind of start over to a
degree and it sort of gives her
something to live for beyond herself
right a chance to
to look at something to say like i can
work for this thing right i can build
on this thing you know i can raise this
child into somebody productive
and admittedly hold on to a portion of
her husband the part of her husband that
she loves so much and so from there you
switch over to a villain mastermind not
a whole lot doing here this guy's kind
of a dick and he does exactly what a man
with the name mastermind would do he
controls the minds of other people
and so ultimately mark and and the
guardians basically get the upper hand
on him and that's that's more or less it
but then you basically end up jumping to
mark meeting with amber but the whole
conversation with amber is kind of this
funny moment right because mark has a
tendency to kind of get caught up in the
moment right not really caught up in
himself
mark's pretty far from being a person
who's full of arrogance and hubris but
but it's one of these things where he's
kind of like okay so she's like he's
like you know what's
you know you look pretty tired she's
like yeah i was i was up really late and
you know i've got like a big test in an
hour he's like okay well do you want to
ditch class and go with me to africa and
she's like what did i just say
i got a test in an hour mark
mark doesn't listen but then she's kind
of africa it's africa
you know like how often do people get to
go to africa now here's one of the
things that i want to draw your
attention to because we actually kind of
skept over this in the previous videos
that we've done but here's one of the
things that i want to draw your
attention to
if you guys remember probably from the
tv show assuming that you never read the
comics which i don't know why you
wouldn't be reading the comics but uh in
the in the tv show you had that mission
to mars right you had those weird little
aliens that had the capability of like
taking over and conquering whole worlds
by possessing people
things like that right so one of the
astronauts a guy by the name of russ
livingston is basically a guy who was
left behind right that guy you saw with
like the really dark eyes and he's like
he looks like he would have like the the
kind of laugh a man would have if he had
like a handlebar mustache and he was a
villain like
you know like that kind of a thing well
one of the martians actually made it
back to earth right and so the result of
this is that you do kind of get a little
bit
of of discussion there but this guy kind
of realizes like
given the powers that he has the ability
to shapeshift because he's more or less
invincible's version of martian
manhunter that he can in turn become a
superhero and so that kind of gives you
this answer of
what happened with this this alien that
ended up taking on the form
of of russ livingston and then showing
up on earth now there are caveats here
right the way the the explanation is
given to us he can't necessarily hold
the position
for an exceedingly long amount of time
and even then like with him being on
earth he still
is concerned about his race back on mars
now when i say that he's concerned about
his people
it's more of like more like just the
rebels right because like in the end
he's just kind of like i mean i hated
our monarch right our monarch was like
super corrupt
i'm kind of glad that i got away from
them you know i i hate this
uh it is kind of interesting in terms of
how he sees his own people so i imagine
he probably only really longs for the
rebels and he kind of goes as far as to
say that
right like himself and the other rebels
hated the enslavement of the squids and
and so on and so forth but when you
basically transition to africa
it's kind of this funny moment right
because mark was basically invited here
by eve that mark's mom had given him you
know eve's number when she was out in in
africa and then he had called her and
she was like yeah you know come hang out
so mark brings amber all right here's
the thing
gentlemen gentlemen fellas guys out
there who
are not very good at picking up on clues
right
one of the most frustrating things with
the nature of the game when it comes to
the lady folk to the to the women folk
is that they never really tell you when
they're digging you right sometimes they
do but it's usually dropping subtle
hints and i guess part of the game is if
you can pick up on it and kind of build
up that tension right other times it's a
pain in the ass you know it's just like
all right whatever man i got more
important things to do but this is one
of those times man
when a girl that you know digs you is in
another part of the world and says hey
come hang out
you do one of two things right either
you're with like your mark and you're
with a girl and you say look i'd love to
but like you know
i'm with a girl right now so let's let's
table this right now or if you're single
you're like let's go man
that's all that is and she's trapping
all the hints man like she's just
literally telling him that she digs him
and it's kind of funny because mark just
seems
oblivious to it right like like that guy
like mark is that guy and so it's just
like okay mark come on man this is one
of the cool things about adam eve's
character too though
robert kirkman and he all he does it so
subtly adam eve i would argue
is probably the most powerful of all the
characters that exist out there
because she can alter matter on an
atomic level now if this was a marvel
comic mark would be like man like how
advanced can this be and she's like
i can conquer the universe and she would
just ascend and become a cosmic entity
and then she would just hover in the
stars forevermore
and then appear every once in a while
because she's a plot device now like
that's what marvel comics would do
i love what kirkman does right this is a
girl that can control matter on the
molecular level and it's just kind of
like
yeah man like it's a thing that she can
do right she can just kind of
will things into existence but it's also
a little bit of a learning curve here
because not even adam eve is fully aware
of everything that she can do and she
even says that right like she's
learning to use her powers in a more
complex way it's one of the reasons why
she came out here one to kind of get
away from everything but two to explore
full capabilities when adam eve
reaches like her full potential which
she will she is a
demon it's insane how powerful she is
right like she just gets
to this ridiculously op level but mark
also does like a little bit of catching
up with it right because like he
basically tells her like i've got a
little brother and it's like what
you talk to your dad what like your
dad's married to like a bug
what like what is going on here and so
he does like the
the whole kind of spill in the beans
right and more or less everything that
we've kind of caught up with here and
everything that we've sort of discussed
here and then while the two of them are
talking
they realize amber's over there now this
is a funny depiction of our character
because one of the things that kirkman
kind of hits on here when it comes to
the the various parts of invincible
is he almost kind of portrays people who
are superheroes as kind of a higher
caste or a higher order not in so far as
how they conduct themselves right i mean
you don't have marks for you know flying
around i look down on you that's not
really what he the the kind of
philosophy he has
but uh but that's not really how he
operates it's really more of the
depiction of amber like one of the
things that uh
that adam eve really picks up on here is
like amber never looks up right she
almost never ever looks up to the sky
she's always just kind of looking
forward or just kind of looking around
right just you know just kind of minding
your own business but it's one of these
things where amber's kind of depicted
here as a person
that in the grand scheme of things isn't
really striving for much in this life
right she's just kind of striving for
just good enough
and and i say just good enough in
relation to people like mark or people
like adam e
i mean granted they have abilities that
amber simply just doesn't have but with
having enhanced capabilities not just
powers but with enhanced capabilities
enhanced
access to things comes enhanced
abilities to achieve more in this world
right it's really kind of establishing
this idea
that amber's just not for mark right i
mean they're just it's just
not really supposed to be that way but
it also kind of reflects itself in the
conversation like adam even market had
and the sense that that mark was kind of
talking to her about how her and amber
have kind of gotten into a few fights
here and there and that's par for the
course when you're in a relationship you
do get into arguments you do get into
fights you do get into disagreements
right because what's a relationship if
you're not taking two people who don't
know anything about each other
slapping them together and saying now
make it work basically what it is so of
course you're gonna have some
disagreements and so on and so forth but
the various issues that amber and mark
have been dealing with a lot of it came
from
mark's deception right in the sense that
mark didn't really tell her he was a
superhero initially he would just
disappear for huge amounts of time
and then return home and she'll just be
there with open arms then in effect she
would kind of put her life on hold to a
degree and so far as like what it means
to have a significant other
because of his superhero escapades we
don't know if that's something that she
can cope with
adam eve is far more of a compatible
person
for mark than amber is at least on that
level but mark kind of counters that and
he says yeah but like we have a lot in
common there's a lot of things that we
like but one of the things to know about
relationships that one percent makes all
the difference
you can find somebody who's 99.9 percent
compatible with you but depending on
what that 0.1 percent makes up it could
be a deal breaker right like it's
like that like that 0.1 percent could be
i don't want to have kids
and that right there totally tortures
the relationship right your your deal
breakers and so it's kind of an
interesting thing there
because you end up having uh mark who
really kind of gets a phone call here
uh while he and adam eve and amber are
hanging out and this is kind of like
mark help right she's in trouble mark
how fast can you get home like it's his
mom and then somebody somebody basically
answers alongside his mom and mark
boltz he's just like eve can you get
amber home and she's like yeah he's like
okay cool gotta go bam and then just
bolts
right just like immediately takes off
when he gets back home he's met with
angstrom levy now
angstrom levy is a character that we
haven't really talked about yet right
and he was kind of covered a little bit
in the previous stories that we did in
all honesty i didn't cover him at the
time because i didn't want to mess up
the pacing of the story to kind of have
this this cohesive discussion
about what happened to omniman after he
left earth and then suddenly sidetracked
to angstrom levy but the idea behind
this
is that at a previous point in time
angstrom levy had actually come into
contact with an alternate reality
version of himself and the reason why is
because angstrom can make portals to
different dimensions
and so what he wanted to do or at least
kind of look to to bolster his abilities
and so on and so forth that he ended up
having himself hooked to a kind of
machine of sorts by the mauler twins the
problem with this is that when
invincible showed up that angstrom levy
started summoning all these mauler twins
from other dimensions and then mark was
actually on the verge of being killed
right being beat to death and so
angstrom took the harness off his head
and it created a kind of feedback where
it basically turned him into the version
of himself that you see now but angstrom
is a
wildly powerful character it's one of
these things where his powers are kind
of unique in that way right i mean it's
not as always powerful because he can
just
look at mark and disintegrate him or
like beat him to death because of his
astronomical strength it's just one of
these things where he can just kind of
open portals and that's what he tells
mark
right you know ultimately the whole
reason why he comes after mark for this
is because one
the whole experiment or the whole you
know kind of situation that led him to
becoming who he was
it ultimately kind of erased portions of
the entire incident so he doesn't really
remember things
as they happened instead all he really
remembers are kind of it's kind of like
the big picture of the big picture the
big chunks
but missing the nuance and so it's you
know i was a regular guy
and then invincible showed up and then
invincible face off against the mauler
twins that i brought from other
dimensions
and then like something happened and
then now i'm like this right so
invincible caused this when mark goes to
attack him he opens a portal and then
sends mark to a different dimension
where dinosaurs have more or less become
sentient where they can actually talk
and he escapes by the skin of his teeth
and then comes back through the portal
again
and then goes to attack him uh yet again
and then like another portal's opened up
and he ends up in the marvel universe
and then he actually encounters doctor
octopus and like crashes him
into a building he's like oh dude man
i'm so sorry about that and then bail
right like for one page
he meets he meets doctor octopus right
so then he comes back to the portal
again only this time
the webbing of spider-man follows him
right so hence the title invincible
meets spider-man for like two seconds
like it's it's kind of nuts but it's
small little stuff like this one thing
that i do want to point out here
this concept of like alternate
dimensions that's something that i want
you guys to keep in the back of your
head but it's kind of this cat and mouse
game right
mark is fighting out of emotion he's not
fighting out of logic and remember
that's one of the lessons that his dad
was trying to teach him
you cannot fight emotionally you have to
fight logically whenever you fight
emotionally you're gonna make
just ridiculous decisions and it's one
of the things that ancient levy's
counting on right i remember mark is
young right he's a college age kid but
at the same time he doesn't really have
the experience to know what kind of
rational decisions he should be making
and so
it's one of these things where he goes
to attack yet again because angstrom
knows like the more the the angrier that
mark gets the more reckless he gets and
the more reckless he gets
the less he thinks and so it's one of
these things we just kind of playing
games with him and so he sends him into
a dimension where there was a zombie
breakout right and like everybody in
that world was essentially infected by
zombies and it happens like that
over and over and over again every time
he goes to attack he's sent to a
different dimension
now he's he's he's beaten he's not
necessarily broken
he's kind of tattered he comes across
batman like literally he's like he's
like i mean you dress like a bat and
your name's
what like isn't that kind of lazy
isn't it lazy to dress as a bat and call
yourself batman like
kind of a lazy name and so it's one of
these these sort of weird things
where like he finally just kind of sits
and waits and then eventually a portal
opens up and angstrom sticks his head
through and then he immediately goes to
the portal right and then goes to attack
angstrom levy again
and then yet again angstrom levy opens a
portal and the two of them
actually end up fighting through these
kind of like dimensional waves right
like like literally fighting throughout
the multiverse that's basically what's
happening here they're jumping from
universe to universe
and then the fight's just the two of
them until it gets to a point where mark
basically gets the upper hand
and gets so mad that angstrom threaten
his family that he actually beats him to
death
this is really the first big moment
where the actions of mark
just cost the person their life in
extreme rates right where he remembers
him so he kind of thinks about his dad
right like he he like literally reminds
himself of his dad
and so in that moment there's a huge
kind of crushing sensation here because
it's like oh my god i'm like my dad
i've basically become my dad like this
is this is the person that i've turned
into and so what you end up having is a
portal that opens up
and essentially the guardians of the
globe end up popping out but it's a
future version of their characters
including adam eve now the conversation
here is not
overly lengthy instead what had happened
is that in the
the main universe right the main
dimension of invincible that mark had
just
vanished right so as far as he's
concerned it's it's been virtually no
time at all right within within like a
few hours right all this stuff's gone on
for him for these guardians of the globe
they've been hunting for mark for
15 years they've been trying to find him
for 15
years and they were finally able to
locate him right like they were finally
able to pick him up now it's one of
these things where adam eve goes running
to mark and says okay
here's what you have to do go talk to
the younger version of me and tell her
anything right tell you love her tell
her you don't love her tell her you just
want to be good friends whatever
but if you never ever tell her how you
potentially feel about her
she's going to forever hold on to this
this possibility that the two of you
will end up being together she'll never
have anybody else she'll never really be
able to live a meaningful life because
she will
always hope that the two of you are
going to get together so tell her
whatever it is you need to tell her like
tell her whether
whether you love her or not it doesn't
matter but tell her something and so
that's kind of the crazy thing
is because this sort of sets the stage
on what we saw in this issue that amber
is not the best fit for mark that adam
eve is and it's going to seemingly at
least it kind of appears to
go in that direction of mark possibly
saying something to adam e
whether he does or not is something that
i'm not going to reveal to you at least
not now anyway following that
you end up having essentially a person
associated with cecil who actually shows
up to the house of debra to kind of get
things organized and so far is like the
the little boy the
little kid that kind of was brought here
by mark and so when the question's asked
like have you decided on a name
the response is oliver right like i'm
gonna name this kid oliver it's my
father's name
like mark's mom is effectively adopting
the the stepbrother of mark and the son
of omniman right he's officially going
to be
kind of brought into the family there
and so following this what you do is you
actually pick up with mark going and
visiting the taylor right you guys let
you guys know him arthur rosenbaum but
it's one of these things where the two
of them are kind of talking
and having a conversation and mark's
actually coming to terms with this this
idea of the fact that he had basically
beat a man to death right and he's
coming to terms
with a look on on adam eve's face from
the future when she said she loved him
right just desperation and sorrow as he
describes it he's kind of like i mean
adam eve is my friend you know and and i
like her you know i'm attracted to her
but like at the end of the day if i did
that it wouldn't really be fair to amber
and he says he loves amber but here's
the important thing to understand the
heart wants what the heart wants and no
apologies need to be made for it right
that's just the way that it is i mean in
the in the game of love
somebody's bound to get their heart
broken right it's just it's the nature
of things if everybody returned the
affections of everybody who made
advances towards them then monogamy just
couldn't exist
right so in order to fall in love hearts
have to be broken it's just the way that
goes it sucks and it's not fair but
honestly the world's not necessarily a
fair place and so the so
ultimately it's kind of like what are
you gonna do and so he's just kind of
like i'm gonna stay with amber at the
moment right like amber's the one that
i'm gonna stay with because
she's just been so supportive of me
right i mean like all these superhero
antics disappearing for days or even
months or weeks at a time
you know like all the stuff that comes
with this package of what it means to be
with somebody like me
she's been through it right she's been
you know i wouldn't say thick and thin
they haven't been been together long
enough to really know but he's just kind
of like you know
she's been there for me and i feel like
it'd be wrong to betray that to destroy
that
and then to go with somebody else
because a future version of herself said
hey like i really love you right you
know just because a person says they
love you doesn't mean you have to love
them back
and so ultimately the tailor kind of
goes to a back room and then comes back
and presents mark with these books now
these books are ridiculously important
and the reason why is because when
they're presented to mark mark's just
kind of like i mean what like what is
this
and and you know the taylor's like well
and your father was a would like try to
be a science fiction writer when he
first got here and he wrote a little bit
and he made a little bit of money but
after that they were all just basically
huge failures right so he just started
writing like travel books and different
things like that and so ultimately these
are all handed over to mark
and mark starts looking at him and says
like i mean like look at the names these
names are terrible right hate tribes on
the planet wreck
right this one the man with the
invincible gun and so he kind of starts
coming through it and reading it and as
mark begins to read it he begins to
realize his father's books right when in
the last video when his dad said find my
books and read my books it wasn't
because he just wanted his son to know
that he tried to write science fiction
at some point he's actually
going through and mark realizes he's
writing himself that literally he's just
writing his own stories
about tracking down individuals and
hunting people who were basically
enemies of the viltrumite
empire but each one of these books deals
with like an artifact or a weapon or a
person with extraordinary skills and
that's when mark starts to realize
all these things they're basically
instructions on how to destroy
the viltrumites it's literally a
blueprint on how to win with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you